che ci crediate o meno sti cosi mi
chiamo dati a un raduno delle ragazze
non so se siano più fighi e le antenne
rosa oppure il fatto che dal riflesso
degli occhiali si vede che sto guardando
delle banane ed a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono fa vigente
oggi siamo in un nuovo fottutissimo vlog
prima di cominciare con la setta dei
partiti con la panarda settimana che
questa settimana è stata vinta da non lo
so chi ha fatto sta disegno socialmente
non c'era la firma l'unico problema è
che la foto l'hanno fatta con una
macchina fotografica che fa veramente
schifo
sembra che abbiano scattato questa foto
con una patata sott'acqua al buio e ci
sono ancora le banane nel riflesso degli
occhiali che è bello al nuovo blog fino
ad adesso si trovano tutto il gesto non
so se visto quindi ciò di nuovo il mio
braccio meraviglioso e se non mi tolgo
gli occhiali giuro che la fine serata
diventò anche ragazzi passando a una
cosa epica della giornata quando abbiamo
fatto il film ci sono state un sacco di
fan durante le riprese di scene ed i
bloopers insomma io ho spinto tantissimo
perché la produzione riuscisse a
procurarmi le scene le scene dove
abbiamo sbagliato lo abbiamo fatto dei
file io volevo fare un video reaction su
sta roba che non l'ho ancora visto per
niente perché volevo tenermeli come
sorpresa per privi dei ragazzi sceglie o
pronti sul computer
direi che possiamo fare una reactions de
pronti ragazzi ho io vi avviso è perché
sta roba farà morire aspettato una vita
per vederla però let's go adesso ci
penso io
quello sta morendo sul serio l'unità di
controllo da qui non mi ricordo più
niente
ciò labsus el'alzheimer amico mio
l'alzheimer ricordo assolutamente niente
vero
[Musica]
io ero preso bene gazo unità di
controllo mi permette ad accedere al
mondo diano madonna quante volte abbiamo
rifatto si stronzate texas ha detto
oddio no odio questo spaccato fermi
morto anche lui manifesterà in ajax ai s
l'inglese dai finish the line ai escono
maria io e john e di mettersi al sicuro
stato gli animi no non sono veri giovani
non sono veri giochi non sono religiose
che dici letto da malissimo sono fatto
malissimo e vice del male che attrae a
il tavolo era di metallo e io dovevo
incazzarmi tirandi lasciamo verbo
vietina roba ma cerchiamo di farle buone
perché mi fa malissimo famiglia sta
veramente facendo ma ritornando alle
grazie e poi mi è un po troppo da un
salumiere
sì sì sembra proprio il salumiere mia
stessa faccia a [ __ ]
io ho già detto non posso non approva
affanculo riso è il fattore incredibile
cioè e cosa serve questa chiave mikami
con occhio mai cioè cioè ea cosa cioè e
che cosa serve questa cioè cioè yo yo ma
fermi io rido rido di questa cosa che
sta dicendo che mai in realtà un passato
abbiamo passato giorni così giorni e
dimmi se nella tua vita vorrei mai
qualcosa che ti renderà così così e se
neppure andato e bellissima perché la
scena non è venuta ma lui si gira
tranquillo brown dai radar in bagno
oppure che accade misterioso ragazzo
vero la tipa a sinistra non era nel film
ricordati pali non è l'ultimo ma caldo
sono abbastanza signora sono abbastanza
la tipa non faceva parte il figlio era
lì a caso l'ho fatto apposta era per far
bene e chi no no è un genio in gente
vaga ripreso a male di cicogna scusa ma
dorigatti quali avevo spaccato il dito e
vabbè poi il caro ma ci ha pensato a
ecco baristi giocato facevo la rotolato
hanno chiamato gay era questo che volevo
l'edizione o corrotto tutt'al indiana
production per farmela dare il ragazzo
di clips mi pare che siano andate anche
su paperissima se papere sono mi ricordo
però sicuramente bello faticosissimo ma
veramente figo sa già che ci siamo che
mica provvedimenti visto che siamo in
argomento che in terapia è uscito
l'album è uscito l'album dell'intera di
questo conosciuto il film che minchia
ammesso e con crema è cascato microfono
è uscito l'album league inter ap della
panini noi siamo anche in gran figo come
un figo della madonna va beh come il mio
album vecchio che tra l'altro era andato
un sacco io vi ringrazio di cuore
ragazzi io ho solo il pacchetto quello
di delle edicole tipo pieno a addio se
ne può aprire una caso tipo giusto
prevedere se esco a trovare le foto di
me col dito nel naso anche nell album
dig e intera p4 altri club
c'è solo clapis sisto pacchetto a caso
ormai sono diventato fan di clapis
fantastico che mi ricordavo quando la
piccolo collezionavo quelle dei
calciatori ci sia avessi avuto dei
pacchetti tanti così ma invece di avere
le figurine così aprile ha poi son
diventato grande e sono diventato un
gran figo e quindi aprile non c'è più le
figurine ma ciò la [ __ ]
jones ha messo in cui la manco mia madre
va bene ragazzuoli passiamo al fuori
disponde di oggi visto che siamo in tema
di domande facciamo domande
il blog scorso che ho fatto l'ho
intitolato sono ingessati incidente sono
ingessato per due motivi allora il primo
era per avvertirli ovviamente però mi
sarete chiesti tutti che cazzo ci stai a
fare col gesso e il secondo luogo
ragazzina per attuare un mio piano
malvagio perché ho dato per scontato che
se avessi messo un titolo del genere
avrebbe aiutato a portare qualche ai per
scrivermi stronzate
peccato che non sei morto qualche altra
stronzata dal quoziente intellettivo di
una scimmia e lo faccia apposta in modo
tale da screenare i commenti esmer darli
in questo video quindi ragazzi andiamo a
[ __ ] tre commenti top rating
comments stupidity hdblog più di pai
quindi le pubblici iscriversi si vidoli
monti tu ci crediamo la testa ci dovevi
incastrare dalla portiera la testa acido
di incastrare nella portiera in italiano
c'è scritto che lui non pensa che io non
ti vido miei ma pensa che me li monti
qualcun altro per probabilmente gesù
dovevo incastrare la testa dalla
portiera amico mio ti posso assicurare
che il mondo tutto io
ma proprio tutto monte monto i video
molto le immagini monto tua madre
e alla pesca è l'unico video al collo
messo like sono felice che sia successo
mi dispiace che tu non sia morto
direttamente non so quante persone
conosci che sono morte schiacciandosi un
dito nella portiera della macchina ma
d'altronde ti chiami te alla pesca che
cosa cazzo mi potevo aspettare
wiesel ejei bourne ma che cazzo avete in
testa che gli mandate anzi perché nel
video scorso mentre mandati un
preservativo a caso ma che cazzo avete
in testa che gli mandati preservativi
che non servono a niente affari ha
pienamente ragione ragazzi perché se il
preservativo l'aveste inviato a il papà
di questo ragazzo a tempo debito
magari questo ragazzo in questo momento
non avrebbe inquinato la nostra area già
ragazzi concluso piccola domanda eto'o
packing pro dovevo farlo perché mi dice
io mi diverto un sacco quando mi
facessero non lo so perché non è per
cattiveria perché io vi ripeto a me non
frega assolutamente un cazzo mi scrivono
cose di heitinga me portano
visualizzazioni quindi gli haters mi
fanno un sacchi simo comodo il problema
è che mi diverto e quindi dovevo
metterli anche perché poi farò il
montaggio giulio gualtieri e fare
risponde ti piacerebbe avere dei figli o
vent'anni non so che cosa
minchia no adesso no forse il futuro può
essere ad ora come ora sai manco la
barba come posso pensare di avere un
figlio li crescerebbe la barba prima di
me ma altre date fa risponde e vero che
hai l'uccello grosso e nero da kyoto
ragazzi come quello che il blog è stato
stato stranissimo comunque le papere
fanno parte della nostra esperienza sul
set e quindi hanno un valore anche
sentimentale ci tenevo a condividerle
con voi prima di concludere passiamo
alla fase domanda che la farina manda di
oggi e vi fate sapere nei commenti un
vostro epic fail un qual cosa avete
fatto nella vita di fail modo tale che
lo possa commentare nel prossimo vlog
farò una compilation dei migliori fail
che sono successi alle persone quindi se
vi è capitato di fare un qualche epic
fail scrivetelo passato nei commenti e
io commentero i più belli quindi ragazzi
che un quello che episodio spero che
bisogna sempre ceduto e colasanto video
piaciuto il documento è un mi piace è
peccato non c'è più gesto caf però
lasciato lo stesso mi piace
e perché all uccello nero anche la
faccia di facebook e con e video a
trattare tiziana sensi di scriveteci
vediamo il prossimo video bella ragazza